so over the past couple weeks have been
advising a friend of mine to share her
journey on youtube and check her store
and what she's going through and that
would help people connect to her better
and want to join her on her journey and
I realized that I haven't been sharing
too much about what I'm up to and
thought that would be an interesting
video maybe make it a series so it is
now the start of April what day is it
today April today is April second of
film and we'll see when this video
actually goes live and I thought I tell
you what I'm working on and maybe you
guys can contribute and share the
biggest thing right now that i'm working
on with my business is i'm looking for
i'm looking for bigger stage
opportunities i'm looking constantly now
for ways that I can reach more people
and have a greater impact this is this
is what consumes me this is what
frustrates me I've spent the past I
don't know how many months working on my
youtube videos and getting better and
they're at the point now where I can
watch them and be happy with them and
not you know be embarrassed by them and
you're always critical of your own stuff
now they're good enough now I feel like
they're good enough and now want to
reach more people and I look at the
youtube channel and last month we had
200,000 over 200,000 views on the
channel a year ago I had 25,000 views
for the month on the channel that's the
massive growth over the year and I don't
do advertising I don't really do a lot
of promotion on it's just been people
find in them and subscribing and watch
another one and another one another one
and I really appreciate all you all your
guys support like that that stuff keeps
me going but now I feel like I've got it
get it bigger better you know I want to
reach more people I wanted to be a
million a month I wanted to be higher
you know it feels like it's still slow
growth I came back from Malaysia not too
long ago and did a presentation there
and I did three presentations there that
were really moving and exciting and the
audience loved it and afterwards were
coming back and taking pictures and I
felt I felt what I felt at home there I
felt like that was what I was meant to
do and I'm frustrated that i don't have
the video that he promised me the video
I want to share with you guys but I
haven't gotten the back yet and I feel
like I need to do more of those kinds of
opportunities where it's a big audience
big room more speaking more media and
I'm trying to figure out how to go about
that usually when I set my mind on
something I start to see those things
happen so it's i'm sure more gonna be
coming up but that's that's the biggest
thing that I'm working on I love more
can my youtube channel and I'm just
trying to figure out how to get to a
bigger stage a lot of you guys already
commenting on the video saying things
like I don't know why more people
haven't seen these videos it's coming
it's happening i know and it's been
awesome growth I just wanted to happen
faster you know typical entrepreneur I
want to know anyway so I have a few
other exciting things I'm working on I'm
working on a book deal I've had to carve
out one of my days tuesday i used to do
more admin email stuff monday and
tuesday would do that kind of prepare
myself for the week now I've crunched
all that down into Monday saw Tuesday I
could work on my book and I'm excited
about it maybe I'll reveal a little bit
more next time working on my zucca
guides working on the YouTube videos for
the videos i'm trying to think of a way
to to add some variety to it i love all
the questions that come in i get so many
questions and it's on honestly awesome
people answer them for you i'm trying to
figure out how to get more maybe me
helping people on camera i don't know if
i go to their business or have people
come to me or if I'm traveling I find a
lot of people are shy at the on-camera
so I'll to overcome that obstacle people
um but anyway the biggest thing still
that that I'm frustrated on and working
on is the bigger stage how to get more
people faster and looking for the
opportunities to really have a mark undo
speaking engagements where where it can
really help move you know thousands of
people at a time so that consumes me it
frustrates me we'll see how the next
month goes if you guys have thoughts let
me know I'm always open to ideas and let
me know you think if you like this
series if you want a monthly update on
me and what I'm up to and questions that
I might have leaving a comment section
below and I'll try to remember to do it
again and we'll see where I'm at next
one thank you everybody for watching
again you guys are amazing and really
keep me going every day I love answering
your questions I love the energy that
you guys give off and i love the believe
team that we've created so keep
believing thank you so much and I'll see
you soon